welcome to the second channel the place
where I post all the stuff that doesn't
require painstaking hours of saying the
same line over and over to get the
phrasing just right this video is going
to be about all of the supplementary
notes to the video I made a few weeks
ago on the complex problems with writing
mental illness infection I originally
had another idea on how to do it about
the history of mental illness
representation and how that's changed
and how that affected people but it
evolved as I was writing it but the
result was I essentially had an entire
second essay written out full of stuff
discussing the Enlightenment and
romanticism and early pharmacology and
Shakespeare and I did touch on some of
these things very briefly in the final
video but I didn't go into it in the
depth that it deserves or I had
available to me and that was because I
really wanted to keep the the argument
focused on what I was discussing there
which I felt was a very important key
idea and this was just sort of like
surrounding context interesting but not
vital but before we get started remember
the charity stream for 24 hours on
December 6th it'll be for crisis ticks
lines all proceeds go to them it'll be
great to have you here on YouTube well
on my main channel put it in your
calendar have you done it yet go to now
and then come back to the video okay
let's go we're just gonna go through
some of the really cool notes that I got
and we're gonna do it while I'm wearing
my favorite t-shirt see it's cut could
tire on it I really love this shirt I
have like a few Avatar shirts but this
is this is my favorite and I'm wearing
sting there we go so mental illness has
always had some kind of representation
historically Shakespeare's Hamlet you
know is is to be or not to be speech is
a surprisingly good exploration of
suicidal ideation and then they were
characters like Agamemnon who would show
signs of like neurosis but none of these
characters were really you know they
were 10 like mental illness stories like
we know with them today
it didn't really gain a foothold me told
us and really gain a foothold until
romantic IRRI and that kind of came out
as a response to the Enlightenment now
stay with me the Enlightenment was this
kind of broad movement across Europe to
emphasize things like liberalism
humanism science reason and it sort of
challenged the ideas of doctrine and
faith and those are great ways to think
but we saw in fiction that you know
characters who emphasize reason and
logic they became the protagonists and
more emotive and faith-filled people
were listen telogen Talisa and the
Romantic era was something of a response
to this kind of thing romantic writers
and artists and musicians saw the
Enlightenment as losing the value of
seeing the world through emotion
subjective imagination otherworldly
experience and faith and it's because of
this that romantic writers needed a plot
device to explore the world in a way
that science couldn't and this is a
quote from Stella Swain madness in the
nineteenth century is predominantly an
intellectually marginalised land of
fiction which deals with the treacherous
other nests of mad experience which is
often aligned with the supernatural so
we're seeing an emergence of connection
between kind of madness or mental
illness and the supernatural or the
Otherworld you know the divine that sort
of thing and there's actually a really
nice poem from Wordsworth which kind of
hints at this idea came out in the
Romantic era some call it madness such
indeed it was if prophecy be madness of
things viewed by poets of all time a may
in these two two days no more be seen
with the disordered site that's 1799
Wordsworth called out the prelude and if
a kind of two ways the mental illness
was broadly seen in this era the first
is the ability to see beyond human
perception Shakespeare represents
psychic extremity in Hamlet and King
Lear as raising the main protagonist
level of awareness beyond that of other
characters in drama exceptional or
visionary states of consciousness
consciousness are central to romantic
ideology so we see that in Shakespeare
and Shakespeare at this point by the way
was having a resurgence it's not that
Shakespeare was resting during the
Romantic era but that Shakespeare was
used by romantic artists and writers
they sort of thought hey these are great
look at these they really emphasize them
as stories fundamentally it was
supernatural means illness kind of had
the supernatural quality to it because
it was quote unleashing the most potent
and enigmatic capacities of the
imagination and Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein is a really good example of
this vector the mad scientist is
described numerously as suffering from
some kind of psychosis with
hallucinations and possibly depression
but this mental condition is actually
linked to its genius and an exceptional
state of mind that leads him to create
life with the creature and the second
way the mental illness was commonly seen
was through the sentimentalist novel in
the late Romantic era sentiment sells
novels typically use me to illness and
eventual death as a way to punish those
characters who committed sexual sin and
that's a quote from kte
walk it takes on a role markedly similar
to a venereal disease which is just a
horrible take it was not uncommon as a
viewpoint that many people brought it
upon themselves through a lack of
moderation in various avenues of their
lives in the 18th and 19th centuries see
the role of mental illness eventually
took a pretty dark turn in the gothic
novel which if you're not familiar with
is a particular kind of romantic novel
with kind of gothic castles and
architecture and a big emphasis on place
and landscape and the supernatural and
ghosts it's that suicidality and
oppression and your mind breaking was
seen as a punishment for sin especially
sexual sin as such the gothic novel
instead very easily shifted mad people
into the other category which it's so
often exploits to create sinister
threatening scenes shallow pontus novel
Jania is the quintessential example of
this the character of Bertha Mason is
incredibly violent she's kind of the and
tag
mystic force of the film sort of and she
exhibits signs of neurosis and suicidal
ideation and schizophrenia but she ends
up this way because she's depicted as a
manipulative seductress who supposedly
plead the husband and the story into
being with her with her husband being
the victim of such immorality Bronte can
Nix her madness to the supernatural
describing her as an animalistic demonic
force with her madness akin to a
vampiric curse not great representation
like two out of ten what one out of ten
the gothic novel didn't just passively
alienate the mentally ill but it
actively encouraged their ostracization
and other necessity that they are not
one of us they belong over there with
the rabbit demon people and encouraging
their exclusion from society a fictional
sentiment that really coincides with
mental asylums then do exactly just that
yeah not even kidding the whole kind of
like put them in prison
what do you mean prison knows it's it's
it's not prison that they're there to
help them but you can pay money to throw
apples at them yes that's a thing that
happens that you go through mental
asylums and pay money to like throw food
at them into the ill G's humanity's
awful but this will see it going through
the Enlightenment Romantic era the late
Romantic era with the gothic novel
things do begin to change with the Garth
of psychology as a scientific field and
psychoanalysis and behavioral analysis
becoming a thing a new way to see mental
illness and suddenly madness or mental
illness was no longer inexplicable it
wasn't an experience of of the
otherworldly forces but well it was
something that could be explained
scientifically and reasoned through and
treated there's a really interesting
quote from Stella Swain about this as
well
once madness is made to render up its
threatening enigmatic status to the
clinical gaze
it also gives up its position as other
as linked to the supernatural as always
beyond an external to the rational self
it is no longer unnatural or even
irrational in particular a new era of
fiction was kicked off and roundabout
1918 just a totally inconspicuous year
any idea why
yeah so World War one came to an end and
suddenly thousands millions of guys were
coming home with PTSD from the war they
were traumatized from this horrific
experience and suddenly a huge
proportion of the population were
returning to society very mentally ill
they called it shell-shocked at the time
and this need for a more categorical and
clinical approach to PTSD and other
mental illnesses led to the creation of
the first dears in this is the
diagnostic manual I can't choir me but
the full title is off the top of my head
but it's basically a very important book
that catalogs all of the mental
illnesses and ways to treat them and
stuff suddenly men weren't depressed
violent seeing and hearing things
because of a supernatural curse but
because of trauma and things in their
past like war this new perception of
mental illness did spark a new era of
fiction and that transformed the role
that mental illness and to mentally ill
people played infection in if scott
Fitzgerald's Tender is the night the
character dick descends into obsession
alcoholism and it takes on an
antagonistic role in the story as kind
of a corrupting force in his life after
his father's death his public
humiliation and eventual loss of his job
possession mental illness like
depression but in particular violence
began to be explained infection by
trauma or the character's past
over time it became a justification for
villainy a logical consequence but to be
Leigha it was still seen as a character
flaw a deficiency in who you are and in
the y-nough society the belief that
mental illness was a punishment for
being bad or at least that it was
associated with being immoral persisted
even if clinical circles began to change
their approach these kind of people just
kind of acknowledged that there were
logical or rational reasons for being
that way but the change was still slow
so throughout the early 1900's we get
loads of villains and antagonists and
even some protagonists whose
justification for evil acts were madness
schizophrenia or mania those were really
common ones in particular and we started
to develop what hilar called five
archetypes when it came to characters
with mental illness you'll probably
recognize some of these the homicidal
maniac think psycho the narcissistic
parasite the female seductress patient
which you can see sort of in characters
like Bertha Mason the rebellious free
spirit and the especially gifted and
well I got a bit to that in the video
itself but that one is probably the most
common today you probably noticed the
the the especially gifted mentally ill
person that one's a really common one
these days three out of five are
actively negative they're bad things and
they're always portrayed as bad things
and the fifth is pretty neutral so
mental illness representation didn't
really see progress if we define
progress is like good representation in
the 19th so much as we saw an evolution
of how it was negatively portrayed from
a supernatural curse to a justification
for evil our understanding increased but
our empathy didn't increase that much it
did a little bit but I think it would be
an overstatement to say that the 1900's
were an era of empathy no things only
really began to change in terms of
mental illness representation when it
came to the post modern era
which began sometime in the 1950s and
continued through to around the 1990s we
discussed the role of post-modernism
briefly in the video but I like to go
into a little bit more detail here and
for whatever you might have heard about
post-modernism there's a really good
quote from Daniel Bukowski at Professor
P danteís that I think summarizes the
movement for the purposes of the
discussion in this video there is an
emphasis on multiple realities and
distrust of totalizing discourses
fragmentation irony pastiche and collage
essentially postman works began to
question the dominant ways of thinking
about the world and this included the
idea that mentally ill people were
dangerous violent or otherwise stories
like Catcher in the Rye and the bell jar
by Sylvia Plath do this
slaughterhouse-five has a character
suffering from PTSD and infinite Geist
has addicts as protagonists and a really
common way to do this would be to take
people from a marginalized group and
place them at the center of the
narrative in hopes to get the reader to
empath eyes with them and empathize with
their struggles in the real world to
question the way we think about this
marginalized group in particular so we
see stories like Catcher in the Rye or
the bell jar by Sylvia Plath which do
exactly this slaughterhouse-five has
characters suffering from PTSD and
infinite Geist has addicts as
protagonists addicts also being a
marginalized group my personal favorite
is Blade Runner people who know me will
know that I love Blade Runner it's just
a fantastic story but they use
replicants they are the oppressed
outsiders of the story scene as violent
and lissa and the writer places them at
the heart of the story to reveal them at
the end as victims their leader Roy
batty is actually positioned as the
antagonist of the story but by the end
of the film Ridley Scott leads us to see
for a Bettie as just a human or even
more human than any of the other
characters in the story the marginalized
other is placed at the center of the
narrative and we see the world from
their point of view and empathize with
them early postmodern works actually
dealt more with things like six
in drugs because those were the taboo
topics that were really popular in the
day as kind of we emerged through the
nineteen fifties sixties seventies but
towards the 80s and 90s new things began
to be included including mental illness
that sort of came to the forefront as
well and we didn't just have characters
who were having sex outside marriage and
doing drugs or were addicted to drugs
but characters who were suffering from
suicidal ideation depression and
schizophrenia and they weren't seen as
character flaws and this was kind of the
revolutionary idea they were seen as
character struggles things to be
overcome things that they weren't
responsible for necessarily the things
that they struggled against nevertheless
and this was a major difference in kind
of how they approached it in fiction
even in the early 1900's there was still
this distinct idea that even though it's
a struggle that they have they are
ultimately responsible for it that
they've sort of got it because of the
way they acted they were too weak or
something like that there are still
logical causes but it's because they
were too weak it's their problem
no that's no longer the case and these
later postmodern works you know really
exposed I think a new way of approaching
it and that was really good that was
really good and we see it we see how
that's bleed into fiction these days we
see how it's had a really positive
impact and now we have a whole lot a lot
of characters who are really real
grounded relatable and their struggles
are meaningful and not dismissive and I
love that and that's how the stigma
began to be undermined and there's still
a stigma today but it's a lot less than
it used to be which is great but uh yeah
those are honestly most of the notes
that I've got I've got some other quotes
here and there about you know means
illness and stuff I bet but that's kind
of the broad context in which this whole
video can can take place and fit I hope
you found this interesting it was still
fun to put together and I'm really happy
I get to share with you do share the
video with someone else if you find if
you think that find it interesting
I plan to do more videos on this channel
working on it leave me any any questions
you've got down below if you're curious
and let me know how you approach it in
your story but yeah Stan early and I'll
see you in the future